ich bin auch Kanzler der ungeimpften das
hat Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz im großen
Bild am Sonntag Interview gesagt heißt
er ist auch Kanzler von Bürgern die
vehement gegen die corona-maßnahmen und
eine mögliche impfpflichtprotestieren
dies hier sind Bilder aus der
Vergangenheit nach den Plauen in Sachsen
ja aber auch an mehreren anderen Orten
ist das leider landesweit Geschehen am
dramatischsten war die Lage im
thüringischen Greiz dort müssten auch
Rechtsextreme bei den Demonstrationen
mit sie ließen ihrer wutfreien Lauf 14
Polizisten wurden dabei verletzt es
findet eine deutliche Radikalisierung
statt und darüber wollen wir jetzt mit
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer bei uns im
Studio sprechen Jan Demos gegen die
corona-maßnahmen gab es ja schon länger
warum plötzlich diese Radikalisierung
also prinzipiell muss man einmal sagen
Demonstrationen sind ja überhaupt
erstmal unproblematisch und es ist gut
dass in diesem Land demonstriert werden
kann aber der Punkt ist immer glaube ich
die rote Linie und die darf nicht
überschritten werden die rote Linie wird
dann überschritten wenn es zu
Radikalisierung kommt wenn es zu Gewalt
aufrufen kommt wenn es zu Gewalt kommt
und wenn es wie wir ja auch gesehen
haben sogar zu Androhungen
möglicherweise auch weiterer Straftaten
bis hin zu Mord aufrufen oder Totschlag
kommt so und genau diese rote Linie das
ist das was wir sehen die wird halt
immer
öfter jetzt überschritten woher kommt
dieser Radikalisierung diese Gruppen die
Stacheln sich ja gegenseitig auf unter
anderem in sozialen Netzwerken wie
telegram da gibt es so gut wie keine
Einschränkung so gut wie niemanden der
auch mal dazwischen geht der auch Dinge
löscht wenn beispielsweise es zu Mord
aufrufen kommt und genau hier besteht
dann so etwas wie eine sich selbst
beschleunigen der Echokammer da ruft
jemand auf und sagt das wäre doch ein
gutes Opfer Person XY er sagt der
nächste finde ich auch finde ich auch
finde ich auf dem plötzlich gibt es eine
kleine Gruppe die der Meinung ist sie
ist irgendwie in der Mehrheit und
beschleunigt sich in ihrer Radikalität
und das ist die große Gefahr die wir
hier auch in diesen Gruppen bei diesen
Demonstrationen sehen Jan wir wollen mal
schauen was da ganz genau geschrieben
wird auf dieser Plattform telegram und
hier ist der Beitrag dazu
möge Kretschmer und seine war sein samt
seinen Spitze in diesem Chat jämmerlich
zugrunde gehen dann erfüllt sich
vielleicht mein Weihnachtswunsch ihm auf
sein Grab zu pissen dieser Typ ist doch
sowas von irre mit Worten ist das
Verbrecher Schwein nicht zu stoppen
Kretschmer muss hängen null Toleranz mit
diesem Despot das Schwein Kretschmer
muss egal wie zum Fall gebracht werden
es reicht jetzt sollte es an der Zeit
sein dem Traub die Stirn zu bieten so
nicht wie auch immer man es macht er
muss den Druck spüren es gibt keine
Hilfen für diese desaströsen und
inkompetenten regierungsfritzen ab an
den Galgen mit denen denkt immer dran
sie haben uns den Krieg erklärt
das also Äußerungen die sich gegen
Sachsens Ministerpräsident Michael
Kretschmer richten eine absolute
Hemmungslosigkeit ist da entstanden
völlig inakzeptabel und hier müssen alle
Sicherheitsbehörden nicht nur die
Polizei war alles was auch in Sachen
Landeskriminalamt gibt der
Verfassungsschutz natürliche ran und
müssen diejenigen
festnehmen und dingfest machen die hier
solche Aufrufe und solche Hetze
verbreiten das ist nicht mehr zu
tolerieren das ist eingangs ja auch
gesagt das sind nicht nur Querdenker
oder rechtsradikale die sich da auch
positionieren was kann man denn tun wenn
man einfach mit diesen ganzen
corona-maßnahmen vielleicht nicht so da
Chor ist und trotzdem eine Stimme haben
will und auch gehört werden möchte wäre
gut zu demonstrieren ist ja im Prinzip
kein Problem es wird jetzt des öfteren
kritisiert dass ich die die
demonstrieren die friedlich
demonstrieren nicht abgrenzen von denen
die jetzt wirklich Hass und Hetze sehen
die sogar zu Gewalt aufrufen und sogar
gewalttätig werden also hier muss es zum
einen einen klaren zu geben und du
sprichst einem Problematik die wir sehen
die AFD liegt derzeit bei rund zehn
Prozent kann zumindest noch nicht so
richtig profitieren von dem rechten
rechtsextremen Spektrum was ich da auf
diesen Gewalt Demonstrationen zum Teil
auch jetzt schon gesammelt hat aber was
ist eigentlich wenn ich gegen die
Impfpflicht bin und mich aber als ganz
normaler Demokrat in einem
demokratischen Spektrum befinde dann
habe ich wenn ich in den Bundestag
schaue schon ein Problem es gibt eine
Partei ganz rechts aus dass die AFD die
ist gegen die Impfpflicht und dann gibt
es einige Abgeordnete bei cdu/cs und bei
der FDP sind auch dagegen aber das grow
der Partei ist dafür und wir kommen da
in ein Problem du sprichst es vollkommen
nicht an was kann ich tun als Bürger ich
kann nicht viel tun ich darf bloß nicht
in die extrem kommen ich muss einfach
meine Meinung immer wieder sagen die
muss ich kundtun auch auf
Demonstrationen gehen aber dann gehen
wenn diese Demonstration kippen und
radikal werden und zu hassen Hetze
aufrufen unsere Portal Simone Sura hat
sich mal in München auf der Straße
umgehört ja was die Menschen dazu sagen
ob sie auch Angst vor dieser
Radikalisierung haben
verstehen sie die Wut oder die Angst der
Impfgegner ja gut die Wut und die Angst
der Impfgegner ist nicht für mich
nachvollziehbar weil einfach die Impfung
wichtig ist meiner Ansicht nach und wir
ohne die Impfung nicht so weit werden
wie wir jetzt schon sind ich wundere
mich sehr darüber dass man mehr Angst
hat vor den Nebenwirkungen einer Impfung
das gibt es zweifellos als vor der
tatsächlichen Erkrankung die auf der
Intensivstation enden kann ich verstehen
ja ich meine das ist eigentlich
irgendwie ein Diskriminierung auch wenn
man selbst auch geimpft ist so top
geimpft ist nein also ich verstehe das
nicht das ist ein bisschen dumm für mich
und nicht nachvollziehbar weil
wieso lässt man sich nicht impfen haben
sie Angst vor einer Radikalisierung der
Impfgegner kann ich so nicht abschätzen
weil ich bis jetzt noch keine Impfgegner
kennengelernt habe die die sagen wir mal
irgendwie radikal waren
glaube ich nicht ich habe es erlebt hier
an der Münchner Freiheit da haben sie so
kleine Zettel ausgehängt an der
Wäscheleine mit was für alles furchtbare
passt Dinge passierten und wer uns alles
belügt also ich finde die gruselig wenn
ich die sehe weil diese Demos machen
bisschen aggressiv sind aber sonst
Radikalisierung denke ich nicht weil der
mehrteil würde ich sagen doch eher
vernünftiger ist und sich impfen lassen
wollen würde es hat keinen Sinn die sind
einfach zu betoniert tut mir leid
ja zugeschaltet ist uns peter Neumann
eine Sicherheitsexperte vom King's
College in London
zugeschaltet ist uns der
Sicherheitsexperte peter Neumann vom
King's College in London hallo Herr
Neumann guten Morgen
wer sind diese Menschen die dort
zunehmend protestieren
es kommt darauf an wir haben eine
ziemlich große Bewegung überall in
Deutschland die ist sehr unkonsolidiert
da laufen unterschiedliche Leute mit in
Teilen Deutschlands in Sachsen Thüringen
wird die Bewegung ganz klar von
Rechtsextremisten dominiert die sind
dort vorherrschen in anderen Teilen
Deutschlands sind sie die Minderheit
also in Nordrhein-Westfalen zum Beispiel
höre ich aus Sicherheitskreisen da wird
geschätzt ungefähr nur 15 Prozent der
mitlaufenden sind rechtsextreme und das
ist auch interessant weil bei dieser
Bewegung viele Leute das haben auch
Studien gezeigt viele Leute mit dabei
sind die sich politisch noch nicht
engagiert haben also Esoteriker
Anthroposophen
Homöopathen das wird sich alles noch im
Laufe der Zeit konsolidieren es erinnert
ja so ein bisschen auch an diese
pegida-bewegung wo aus einem konkreten
Anliegen damals ging es um Islamismus
dann sozusagen ein Sammelbecken der
unzufrieden wird dass man gar nicht mehr
klar definieren kann ist das ähnlich
es ist insofern ähnlich als dass die
Leute natürlich auf die Straße gehen und
als dass diese Bewegung relativ
plötzlich entstanden ist was der
Unterschied ist glaube ich ist dass ich
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten schon
eine ziemlich dramatische
Radikalisierung hin zur Gewalt ergeben
hat das war bei pegida nicht unbedingt
der Fall was wir eben in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten bei dieser
corona-leugner Bewegung sehen das sind
Leute die ganz konkrete
widerstandsnallrative formulieren die
sagen wir brauchen jetzt eine
Rechtfertigung dafür müssen uns was
zurechtlegen dass es uns erlaubt auch
Gewalt zu ergreifen und das haben wir
bei pegida so extrem und so schnell
nicht gesehen wie gefährlich ist diese
Radikalisierung geht das bis hin zu
Terror
ich glaube schon ich denke auch dass wir
ja innerhalb der nächsten Monate eine
systematischere
gewaltbewegung aus dieser Bewegung
heraus sehen werden was wir bereits
jetzt sehen ist natürlich schon Gewalt
wir haben Angriffe auch Journalisten wir
haben Angriffe auf Polizisten wir hatten
den Vorfall in Idar-Oberstein wo ein
Beschäftigter in einem Geschäft der
gebeten hat die Maske aufzusetzen
erschossen wurde das haben wir schon was
wir noch nicht haben ist so die
systematische langfristigere Gewalt aber
ich glaube je kleiner die Bewegung wird
desto mehr radikalisiert sie sich und
was wir möglicherweise jetzt schon sehen
ist das Herauskommen von Strukturen
kleineren Strukturen die dann eben auch
systematisch bestimmte Ziele angreifen
werden
können wir von einer Spaltung der
Gesellschaft tatsächlich reden oder ist
das wirklich eine Minderheit die dort
radikalisiert auftritt und der Großteil
der Bevölkerung ist eben nicht davon
betroffen klar also die der Großteil der
Bevölkerung ist natürlich nicht davon
betroffen und insofern ist es keine
Spaltung die jetzt 50/50 ist es ist
schon eine Spaltung insofern dass es
eine signifikante Minderheit ist also
selbst wenn wir von zehn Prozent der
Bevölkerung sprechen dann sind das in
Deutschland 8 Millionen Menschen und
gerade wenn es um das Thema Terrorismus
oder Gewalt geht da brauchen Sie nicht
unbedingt viele Leute dafür und wenn man
da eine Basis hat von was weiß ich
einigen Hunderttausenden und das sehen
wir ja in den sozialen Medien das
durchaus einige Hunderttausenden dieser
Bewegung folgen dann ist das genug um
für die Gesellschaft jede Menge Probleme
zu produzieren Stichwort soziale
studieren die Radikalisierung beginnt ja
dort schon insbesondere auf dem
Nachrichtendienst Telegramm müsste die
Politik da einschreiten beispielsweise
diesen Messenger Dienst verbieten also
ich glaube dass wir schon ganz hilfreich
wenn die Politik bei telegram machen
würde was Sie zum Beispiel bei facebook
macht oder bei Twitter macht dass sie
eben sozusagen versucht die Gesetze
durchzusetzen denn die gelten momentan
auf telegram nicht das Problem mit
telegram ist telegram ist anders als
Facebook oder Twitter ein sehr
mysteriöser Service also man weiß gar
nicht genau wo die beheimatet sind was
das Geschäftsmodell ist wo die überhaupt
sitzen und das ist der Unterschied wenn
man wie Facebook oder Twitter wollen
auch in Deutschland Geld verdienen
deswegen sind sie das sind sie deswegen
sind sie belangbar bei telegram ist das
etwas schwieriger also ich bin mal
gespannt darauf wie die deutsche Justiz
oder wie die deutsche Politik versucht
sich Tele handhabbar zu werden